Ich glaube, das ist ein riesengroßes
Problem unserer Gesellschaft
diese unfassbar schreckliche
Doppelmoral, dass Menschen halt einfach hingehen
und sagen Oh Porno, pfui, pfui, pfui!
Da sprechen wir mal nicht drüber. Aber sich
dann auf der anderen Seite
beschweren, wenn dann halt irgendwelche schlimmen
-Dinge passieren.
-13 Fragen. Hier kommt die erste Frage:
Muss die Pornoindustrie stärker
reguliert werden? Wenn ihr sagt ja, dann bitte
auf das grüne Feld gehen. Und wenn ihr sagt
eher nicht, dann bitte auf das gelbe
Feld. Wunderbar. Jetzt wissen wir,
wo ihr steht. Die Frage ist: Wo steht ihr?
Im Grunde hat ja jeder Mensch in jedem
Alter unbegrenzten Zugriff auf Pornos
aller Art. YouPorn, Pornhub, xHamster,
wie sie alle heißen. Die meisten Inhalte sind
kostenlos und eine zuverlässige
Altersverifizierung gibt es nicht.
Im Grunde ist das auch gar nicht
so schlimm, sagen die einen, denn Pornos
dienen ja in erster Linie dem Vergnügen,
der Unterhaltung und vielleicht sogar
der sexuellen Aufklärung. Und in Sachen
Jugendschutz bringen Verbote schon mal gar
nichts. Na ja, sagen die anderen,
so einfach ist es nicht. Wir müssen
zum Beispiel verhindern, dass Kinder
Hardcorevideos schauen mit entsprechenden
Konsequenzen für die eigene
Sexualität. Und über sexistische
und gewaltverherrlichende Inhalte
haben wir da noch gar nicht gesprochen.
Die große Frage ist also: Braucht
es eine strengere staatliche Regulierung
dieser Pornoindustrie? Und wenn ja,
wie könnte sie aussehen? Meine Gäste heute
sind sich bei dem Thema natürlich
erst mal uneins. Die spannende Frage am Ende
dieser Folge wird sein: Wie schaffen
wir es, Brücken zwischen diesen beiden
Positionen zu bauen, vielleicht sogar
einen Kompromiss zu finden? Jetzt erst mal
die Frage an euch: Wo würdet ihr euch
positionieren? Auf der grünen Seite
oder auf der gelben? Schreibt uns
gerne in die Kommentare. Die Regeln sind ja
einigermaßen klar. Wenn ihr der Gegenseite
in einem Punkt zustimmt, dann seid
ihr herzlich eingeladen, einen
Schritt auf die Gegenseite zuzugehen.
Und wenn ihr sagt: Im Grunde finde ich deine Argumentation
gar nicht so schlecht,
aber in dem Punkt erzählst du
wirklich Mist, dann könnt ihr auch gerne
den Schritt zurückgehen. Mein Ziel
wäre es, möglichst viele von euch am Ende
dieser Folge hier im sogenannten
Kompromissfeld zu versammeln. Mal sehen,
wo ihr heute so landet. Ich bin
gespannt. 13 Fragen habe ich, hier kommt die Frage
Nummer zwei und die geht an Patti. Du
bist Pornodarstellerin. Da könnte man ja
denken, du bist für einen total
freien Zugang zu pornografischen Inhalten.
-Bist du aber nicht. Warum?
-Ich finde, Pornografie ist wichtig für die
Gesellschaft. Da stehe ich definitiv
dahinter. Aber nicht für Kinder.
Und ich möchte da auch ganz klar
unterscheiden. Ich mache einen Unterschied
zwischen Kindern und Jugendlichen. Ich finde,
dass es definitiv reguliert werden
muss, wer sich was anschauen kann.
Ein komplettes Verbot halte ich für völligen
Bullshit. Also das funktioniert gar
nicht. Aber es muss irgendeine Regulation
stattfinden. Exzessiver Pornokonsum
für Jugendliche und Minderjährige halte
ich für extremst schwierig und auch wirklich
gefährlich. Die Problematik,
die wir einfach haben: Alles was wir in Pornos
sehen, ist nicht real. Es ist
gespielt. Und natürlich sind Analsex
oder andere Sexualpraktiken wie BDSM keine
normale Sexpraktiken, die man
unbedingt mit 15, 16 oder 17 ausprobieren sollte
-beim ersten Mal.
-Du hast es jetzt geschafft, innerhalb
eines Statements drei Leute schon
nach vorne zu bewegen. Yma, auch du verdienst
ja auch Geld mit Erotik-Inhalten.
Du stehst aber auf der gelben Seite.
Kannst du ihre Argumentation- Du bist
ihr ja in Teilen gefolgt, aber offenbar nicht
-ganz. Wieso nicht?
-Ich sehe zum Beispiel, dass es wichtiger
ist, dass wir eine Medienkompetenz
entwickeln, dass wir den Jugendlichen
und Kindern beibringen: Wie gehen
Sie an Pornos ran? Und nicht zu sagen,
wir verbieten sie komplett oder wir regulieren
das. Ich finde, den Rest sollte
dafür gesorgt werden, dass wir wissen,
was bedeutet Konsens, was bedeutet Verhütung?
Für mich hatten Pornos eine ganz,
ganz wichtige Rolle in meiner sexuellen
Entwicklung, weil ich zu Hause
selber keine Aufklärung genießen durfte.
Und deswegen habe ich mir Pornos
angeguckt, um zu wissen, was passiert
dort, wie sieht Sexualität aus? Und ich habe
auch gelernt, wie zum Beispiel
verschiedene Vulven aussehen. Ich habe
dadurch gelernt, dass meine Vulva gut so
ist, wie sie ist und ich mich nicht
sorgen muss. Und das haben mir Pornos auf jeden
Fall beigebracht, dass es auch gute
Seiten gibt und dass ich mein Körper dadurch mehr
-lieben kann und nicht nur abstoßen kann.
-Ich würde gerne mal Alex ins Spiel holen,
der vielleicht auch mal aus seiner
eigenen Erfahrung erzählen kann. Wie bist du
mit Pornos in Zusammenhang
gekommen? Was hat das mit dir gemacht? Was hat
das für Auswirkungen auf deine Sexualität
gehabt? Als junger Mensch.
Also mit elf das erste
Porno-Heft mit zwölf habe ich dann blöderweise
eine Person verloren in meinem Leben,
die mir sehr nahe stand, hat unglaublichen
Schmerz verursacht und das hat mich
weiter in diese Welt reingezogen, weil es mich
hat gut fühlen
lassen, mir Pornos reinzuziehen.
-Zu welchen Problemen hat es geführt, dass-
-Krasse Pornosucht! Porno- und auch
Sexsucht? Ich glaube, dass die Pornoindustrie
stärker reguliert werden
sollte, weil die Gefahren vielen nicht
klar sind. Und vor allem der Diskurs über
die Regulierung ist wichtig. Wenn Regulierung
damals schon da gewesen wäre,
sprich irgendwelche Hürden, dann
hätte ich vielleicht mehr darüber nachgedacht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es mich zwingend
gestoppt hätte, also ich hätte meine Wege
gefunden. Ich glaube, dass Jugendliche,
ihre Wege heute auch finden werden,
wenn die Regulierung da ist. Aber es regt
zum Nachdenken an und es ist auf jeden
-Fall ein Teil der Besserung.
-Du warst also lost und hattest nicht das
Bewusstsein dafür, dass es eventuell
problematisch sein könnte?
Nein, weil das Problem ist ja, wenn du
in einem Kumpel/Männer-Kreis oder in einem
jugendlichen Buddy-Kreis bist und sagst
so: ich gucke ziemlich viel Pornos
und ich glaube, ich habe ein Problem.
Wie ist das bei euch? Dann sagen die meisten
auch aus Unwissenheit: Acht, Stell
dicht nicht so an, wir gucken das alle
und wir finden das alle geil. Und dann
bist du an einem Punkt, wo du relativ
wenig hinterfragst und zu spät
vielleicht auch hinterfragst. Und das, das hätte
ich mir für mich gewünscht, dass ich an den Punkt
gekommen wäre, wo vielleicht mal
irgendwer gesagt hätte So, Alex,
dein Konsum, da ist vielleicht ganz schön
-krass.
-Also du hast hier eine Form von
Regulierung, wir reden gleich noch
drüber, Was das genau sein könnte, hättest du dir
gewünscht, aber du hast Umut damit
nicht überzeugt. Der ist nach hinten gegangen.
-Warum?
-Mittlerweile sogar zwei Sachen. Das erste
ist: Deine Erfahrung in allen Ehren
und ich habe Respekt davor, dass du dich hier
outest und so ehrlich bist. Wir haben
die Diagnose Pornosucht nicht.
-Stimmt.
-Das ist mein Ding, was mich in dieser
Gesamtdiskussion, also nicht hier,
sondern im Internet quasi durchaus stört,
dass einfach eine Begrifflichkeit
auch sehr polemisch genutzt wird
und sehr politisch auch genutzt wird,
die wir aber nicht so haben als Diagnose.
Das ist das eine und das andere ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein netter Rückblick
deinerseits ist. Das hätte mir damals
geholfen. Wie viele Menschen werden denn
substanzabhängig, obwohl wir alle
wissen, dass die Gefahr einer Abhängigkeit
besteht? Ab dem ersten Moment, wo man
das ausprobiert. Und trotzdem werden
diese Menschen abhängig, auch wenn sie wissen,
die Gefahr besteht und die machen
einfach weiter, weil versucht wird,
diesen Kick, dass man den irgendwie erreicht.
Zugängen zur Pornografie zu regulieren,
wird sehr wahrscheinlich Erwachsene eher
in die Illegalität treiben und Jugendliche
nicht davor schützen, in Kontakt
mit Pornos zu kommen. Natürlich
gibt es einzelne Menschen, die einen
problematischen Umgang mit Pornografie
haben. Das will ich gar nicht absprechen.
Aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
dass nicht das Medium Porno das Problem ganz
oft ist, sondern: Wie Interpretiere
ich das und wie gehe ich damit um?
Jetzt sprechen wir gerade über
Begrifflichkeiten und Definitionen,
Sexsucht. Und so weiter. Heike
ist weit nach hinten gegangen. Ich habe
-da eine gewisse-
-Spielraum habe ich noch. Von
Sexualtherapeut zu Sexualtherapeutin.
Was entgegnet du?
Zwanghaftes sexuelles Verhalten ist
von der WHO aufgenommen worden als Diagnose
und dementsprechend wird auch weitere
Forschung hinzugefügt und es wird
die nächste Verhaltenssucht
sein. Verhaltenssüchte ist in den Köpfen
der Menschen, in der Bevölkerung und auch von Therapeuten
noch nicht gut bearbeitet
und noch nicht gut vorhanden. Und ich sehe
die Kollateralschäden nämlich
von zwanghaften, süchtigen,
sexuellen, impulsiven Verhaltensweisen tagtäglich
-in meiner Praxis.
-Inwiefern?
Ja, inwiefern in dem Klienten mit hohem
Leidensdruck meine Hilfe in Anspruch
nehmen. Die Pornoindustrie muss
stärker reguliert werden, weil es viele
Kollateralschäden gibt im Bereich
der Gesundheit von Kinder und Jugendlichen,
aber auch von Erwachsenen. Die leichte
Verfügbarkeit von Pornografie kann
einerseits zur Suchtentwicklung
beitragen mit starken persönlichen Konflikten
in der Beziehung,
gesundheitlichen Problemen, erektile Dysfunktion,
Orgasmusverzögerung,
Partnerbezogene Unlust, finanzielle Schwierigkeiten
und eben auch berufliche
Komplikationen. Dass man eben nicht ausgeschlafen
zur Arbeit kommt oder das Studium
nicht fertig bekommt.
Also ganz, ganz unabhängig von offiziellen
Diagnosen und Definitionen kannst du
nachvollziehen, dass es problematische
Bereiche innerhalb des Pornografie-Konsums
-gibt, die sie gerade beschrieben hat?
-Jein. Jein, weil das Problematische in der
Regel ist nicht, dass man
Pornos konsumiert. Warum haben wir keine
Horrorfilmsucht als Diagnose? Da wollen
Menschen auch irgendeinen Kick haben.
Warum haben wir nicht
Extremsport-Sucht als Diagnose? Das Problem ist
die Selbstbefriedigung und dass die Menschen
den Eindruck haben, ich kann mich
nicht mal gegen diesen inneren
Drang wehren und ich kann da nicht so ganz
mitgehen. Weil du selber sagst, das stimmt,
die neue Diagnose, die wir haben,
ist zwanghafte sexuelle
Verhaltensstörung. Aber du hast schon wieder den Suchtbegriff
mit reingeworfen. Hat die WHO
nicht explizit ein Statement abgegeben
und gesagt: Wir distanzieren uns,
wir holen Pornosucht nicht als Begriff
und Diagnose mit rein, wir haben
dafür keinerlei Daten. Ist das erste
und zweitens: Die Forschung
sagt eindeutig, das finde ich viel,
viel spannender, dass gerade
Psychotherapeut*innen, die Sucht
im Zusammenhang mit Sex und Pornos
verwenden, eher die sind, die religiöse
Tendenzen haben und moralische
Einwände gegenüber Sexualität und Pornos.
-Das ist vielleicht ein Problem.
-Das ist der Stand.
-Du darfst natürlich antworten.
-Ich habe zero religiösen Hintergrund, zero
politischen Hintergrund. Ich sehe
die Leute in meiner Praxis und das seit 20
Jahren. Gaming Disorder war auch ein Impulskontroll-Störung
als zwanghafte
Störung zugeordnet und das Bewusstsein
für Verhaltenssüchte entsteht langsam
und Gaming Disorder ist die erste
anerkannte Verhaltenssucht.
Zwanghafte sexuelle Störungen, was sind
dennwanghafte sexuelle Störungen? Ja also
die Klienten, die ihn entwickeln
über eine lange Zeit hinweg, über Toleranz,
Entwicklung, Dosissteigerung das Stadium
des Kontrollverlusts mit weitreichenden
Kollateralschäden im Beruf, im persönlichen
Dasein, in Beziehungen,
in der Sexualität, also auch gesundheitliche
Störungen. Da möchte
ich gerne drauf aufmerksam machen, weil Sucht
und Sex ist etwas, was doppelt Scham
behaftet ist. Das heißt, da wird
oftmals nicht im öffentlichen Rahmen drüber
gesprochen. Und deswegen möchte ich auch darüber
sprechen, weil ich diese Störung
halt tagtäglich bei mir sehen. Und dann
würde ich gerne auch noch mal was zu dir
-sagen.
-Lass und erst mal das sacken lassen, dass
wir das mal kurz hin und her spielen
können. Paulita, jetzt hat Heike gerade
davon gesprochen: Es gibt einen
erheblichen Anteil in ihrer Praxis
von Leuten mit einem großen
Leidensdruck. Kannst du das erst mal nachvollziehen
und anerkennen oder sagst
du: Das ist Quatsch?
Nein, ich glaube, da sind wir uns
einig. Ehrlich! Ich glaube, es gibt viele
Menschen, die leiden in der Gesellschaft
aufgrund von der Art und Weise,
wie Sexualität und Pornografie
gehandhabt wird. Und ich glaube, da sind wir uns
einig, dass da was passieren muss.
Meine Antwort darauf ist: Aufklärung muss
stattfinden. Wir müssen mehr über
Pornografie reden. Wir müssen mehr über
Sexualität reden. Und ich glaube, da finden
wir uns alle zusammen. Und das ist
auch schön. Sexualität und Pornografie
ist immer noch ein Tabuthema,
auch wenn wir denken, dass wir so frei
sind. Und tatsächlich sind wir vielleicht
freier in manchen Aspekten, aber wir sind
immer noch total eingeengt in der Art
und Weise, wie wir mit Pornografie
umgehen. Wenn wir für sexuelle
Selbstbestimmung in der Gesellschaft
sorgen wollen und wenn der Staat
diesen Auftrag einlösen will, dann
müssen wir nicht die Pornoindustrie stärker
regulieren, wir müssen sie fördern.
Aber meine Frage vielleicht zurück wäre.
Ich bin ja keine Therapeutin. Ich frage
an euch. Du redest die ganze Zeit
von Verhaltensstörungen und dann
wirfst du den Begriff der Sucht. Da gibt
es auch einen Unterschied zwischen Sucht
und Verhaltensstörung oder? Also ich bin
keine Ärztin. Ich frage euch:
Warum reden wir von Sucht an der Stelle?
Weil mein Gefühl, meine Wahrnehmung
ist, dass man von Sucht und Pornokonsum geredet
wird, wenn man will. Es wird
suggeriert, Porno sei eine Substanz, die per se
sozusagen süchtig macht. Wie Heroin
zum Beispiel. Und ich glaube, dass das nicht
stimmt. Also Heroin ist tatsächlich
wissenschaftlich geprüft, das verschafft
eine Sucht soll, ein Körper braucht
dieses Zeugs. Aber bei Pornos ist es nicht.
Es ist eine Verhaltensstörung, nicht
eine physische Sucht. Für Alex hat es sich so
angefühlt, wie ne Sucht.
Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Die Frage ist: Ist eine Sucht nicht
eine Verhaltensstörung? Also wie das Wort
und was da schon drinsteckt? Ich kann
mir nicht anmaßen, ich bin kein Therapeut.
Eine Verhaltensstörung ist, wenn ich im Verhalten
mich so gestört präsentiere,
in meinem Umfeld, dass mein Leben
aus den Fugen gerät, ich nicht mehr sozial
kompatibel bin. Und das ist ja genau
bei mir passiert. Ich habe mich stundenlang
in einem Zimmer eingeschlossen,
teilweise wochenlang, habe nur drei Stunden
in der Nacht geschlafen. Freunde
haben sich Sorgen gemacht, konnten es nicht
einordnen. Ich sah aus wie ein Haufen
Scheiße. Also ich hatte auf jeden Fall
eine Verhaltensstörung. Und ich würde
auch sagen, dass wenn ich Pornografie,
was ich immer mal wieder ein paar
Tage geschafft habe, so an die Seite
zu schieben, dass sich dieser Drang
zu flüchten verlagert hat. Also ich habe
auf jeden Fall auch ein Problem.
Jetzt bin ich ja super offen,
auch mit Alkoholkonsum. Dann
trinke ich jetzt auch keinen Alkohol,
weil wenn ich einmal am Fläschchen
sippe, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass ich zehn Flaschen Bier trinke
anstatt eine und nicht Stopp sagen kann,
sehr sehr groß. Genauso war es in meiner
Jugendzeit mit Cannabis und ich beobachte
einfach nur bei mir selber aus der persönlichen
Wahrnehmung heraus,
dass da genau dasselbe passiert bei Pornografie.
Ich nippe an etwas und dann
zieht es mich rein. Und vor allen
Dingen, wenn ich mich schlecht fühle, will ich mir
irgendwie einen Kick holen, der mich
gut fühlen lässt. Und ich glaube,
was ich in meiner Laienhaftigkeit
zu wissen vermag, dass Dopamin eine große
Rolle spielt, das heißt, ein Botenstoff,
der ausgeschüttet wird in mir, der mich
gut fühlen lässt und mich reinzieht
und immer mehr, immer mehr. Und das Problem
bei Pornografie war dann bei mir: Du
ziehst dir einen Film rein. Irgendwann ist
der eine Film hat nicht mehr genug
und dann siehst du in den zweiten Film rein.
Und weil der zweite Film vielleicht
nicht mehr heftig genug ist, ziehst du dir
den dritten rein, der dann
irgendwie Gangbang ist und das Problem
bei dieser Tube-Pornografie ist, die wir heutzutage
haben, da zieht man halt
richtig rein und man zieht
sich immer krasseres Zeug ein.
-Aber alles-
-Was ich sagen will, dann bin ich fertig.
Ich habe das beobachtet, diese Verhaltensstörung
auch in anderen
Bereichen, bei anderen
Konsumverhalten, die eben schon als Sucht kategorisiert
-sind, offiziell.
-Also liegt es auch nicht an der
Pornografie selbst, sondern es liegt
an deinem Umgang damit oder wie du
-mit unangenehmen Gefühlen umgehen.
-Ja, aber ist das mit Alkohol nicht
-dasselbe?
-Klar. Aber du nutzt die Pornografie dafür
-und verteufelst dann das Medium.
-Nein, das tue ich überhaupt nicht.
Und das ist ja nicht das Ding. Das Problematische,
wenn du sagst und dann
der nächste Film und der nächste Film
ist ja, weil man sich in der Regel dazu selbst
befriedigt. Und dann sich nochmal,
nochmal, weil klar, es geht um Dopamin,
es geht darum, dieses gute Gefühl zu erreichen
und auf der Jagd danach sein.
Das stimmt. Aber du könntest auch die Fantasie
nutzen. Machst du aber nicht.
Machen viele Menschen nicht, weil es leichter
ist, etwas Pornografisches
-anzusehen, anstatt den Kopf zu benutzen.
-Ich kann es nicht. Ich kann es, wenn ich
diese Urgents manchmal habe und mir
geht es schlecht. Ich habe schon super oft
probiert, wenn ich dann unter der Dusche
stehe und ich fühle mich irgendwie geil,
will ich mich jetzt selbst
befriedigen? Nein, ich mache es dann nach der Dusche
ziehe ich mir dann doch noch mal
lieber ein Porno rein und manchmal ist
das wie ferngesteuert. Ich kann dann
nicht mich entscheiden in dem Moment. Ich mache
es nicht in der Dusche mit meinen
Gedanken, sondern ich bevorzuge den Porno,
weil es mich da reinzieht. Aber was ich super
deutlich herauskristallisieren
möchte, dass ich Pornografie
überhaupt nicht verteufel. Ich möchte einfach
nur darauf aufmerksam machen, dass wenn jemand,
der das jetzt sieht, Probleme
im Leben hat, die Schmerzen
verursachen, dass das eine eine Welt ist, in die man
sich rein flüchten kann, um diese Schmerzen
nicht zu fühlen. Und dann kann
es verwaltungstechnisch zu Problemen
kommen und das hat nichts mit Vertrauen
-zu tun.
-Das gilt aber nicht für Social Media,
Sport und so, weil ich glaube, das ist
das Relevante. Wir nehmen jetzt erst mal an,
dass Du ein Problem, ich sage mal
mit Pornografie hattest, nicht vielleicht
nicht wegen Pornografie. Wir können ja
den Begriff Sucht auch erst mal beiseitelegen,
sonst streitet man sich ewig über
diesen Begriff. Das brauchen wir auch nicht
machen. Wir erkennen jetzt erst mal
an, du hattest mit Pornografie ein Problem.
-Kannst du das nachvollziehen?
-Ja, total. Also, es gibt Pornografie, die
auf jeden Fall schädlich ist. Die Gewalt
verherrlicht uns weiter. Die eben
für einen zu hohen Dopaminausschuss,
was auch immer sorgt. Aber wäre es da nicht
sinnvoll, beispielsweise Alternativen
zu finden, die weniger dafür sorgen, dass du
dich so reingezogen fühlst, sondern dass man
vielleicht ein bisschen sanfter
rangeht? Es gibt ja ganz viele
verschiedene Arten von Pornos. Man kann ja
nicht Porno verallgemeinern und sagen,
jeder Porno ist gleich und vielleicht hast
du ich weiß nicht welche Pornos du
geschaut, das aber immer die falschen
Pornos geschaut. Und es gibt
natürlich die Möglichkeit das zu regulieren, aber
ich glaube nicht, dass das so ein kleines
Ja/Nein-Feld da wirklich was bringen.
-Also ich bin es immer easy umgangen.
-Super gut. Aber wie willst du das in
dieser Tube-Pornografie Welt
realisieren, wo du das eine Genre neben dem anderen
siehst und der Algorithmus
mittlerweile dir auch schon das ausspielt, was du
vielleicht am häufigsten geklickt
hast und dir noch krassere Vorschläge macht.
Also das ganz, ganz schwer, da eine Entscheidung
zu treffen. So, ich will
-das jetzt nicht gucken.
-Definitiv schwierig. Und ich bin total bei
dir. Das was ich jetzt, nimm das nicht
persönlich, ich glaube, du bist halt
vom Grundsatz her ein Mensch, der schnell
in eine Sucht verfällt, egal welche Sucht
das halt ist. Da ist es natürlich
ungünstig. Also auf so einer Tube-Seite
zu landen. Und natürlich ist der Reiz
nach mehr, höher, schneller, weiter. Den will
natürlich- Es gibt Menschen, die gehen
so wie du es gerade gesagt hast, easy.
Und ich bleib bei meinem. Und dann
gibt es halt die Menschen wie du,
die bis zum Exitus hinausgehen
wollen, was vollkommen in Ordnung, aber schnell
natürlich zu etwas Krankhaftem führen
kann. Und ich glaube, da müssen wir halt
einfach unterscheiden, weil natürlich
stimme ich dir zu. Ja, es ist vielleicht
nicht sinnvoll, sich mit 14/15 Jahren
einen Gangbang anzuschauen, aber ich sehe
das auch nicht als krankhafte
Veranlagung, weil es gibt ja auch einfach Menschen,
-die daran Spaß haben.
-Jetzt haben wir relativ viel darüber
gesprochen, was potenziell für Gefahren
im Raum stehen, wie du sie beschrieben hast,
Alex, die du damit verbunden hat.
Vielleicht können wir auch mal, Paulita,
auf die Ebene kommen, was möglicherweise
eine positive Auswirkung von Pornokonsum
-sein kann oder überhaupt von Pornos.
-Ja, also ich glaube, Pornografie bietet
den Menschen einen Raum, in einem
sicheren, kontrollierbaren Rahmen eben
rauszufinden, was mag ich. Ich kann
mir einen Porno- Vielleicht denke ich,
vielleicht steh ich darauf, aber ich will
jetzt nicht direkt in den Sexclub rennen
und da mit Menschen das ausprobieren.
Ich gucke mir erst mal an im Wohnzimmer.
Was macht das mit mir? Wie sitzt
das mit mir? Ja, vielleicht möchte
ich das tatsächlich ausleben. Oder aber
ich denke mir so: Nee, ich guck das gerne,
aber dabei kann es auch bleiben. Oder Ich denke
mir vielleicht doch nicht meins.
Und das ist eine sehr gesunde Art
und Weise, eben mit der eigenen Sexualität
-sich auszutoben.
-Das ist also eine Art sexuelle Aufklärung.
Ja, es kann eine sexuelle
Aufklärung oder sexuelle Erforschung sozusagen.
-Orientierungshilfe.
-Orientierungshilfe? Ja, vielleicht. Es
kann natürlich auch zum Beispiel ein Dialog
mit einem Partner oder Partnerin
eröffnen, wenn ich vielleicht was was Neues
ausprobieren will, aber ich weiß
nicht genau, wie ich das frage. Wollen
wir uns vielleicht zusammen was angucken?
Ich weiß nicht, ob du drauf stehst,
aber ich finde es interessant und dann kann
das sozusagen der erste Schritt sein,
wie man darüber redet. Also eine Pornografie
kann uns behilflich sein, einfach
besser, gründlicher über Sexualität zu reden
und mehr darüber zu erfahren.
Über uns selbst und unsere Partner*innen
-kennenzulernen.
-Wenn du, wenn ich darauf reagieren darf,
ich bin auch total bei dir, ich gehe
auch nach vorne. Wenn du es nicht
als eine Fluchtwelt
nutzt. Ein anderes Gegenbeispiel.
-Genauso wie Schokolade. Oder-
-Genau Gegenbeispiel aus der Praxis. Ich
habe mir sehr viele Genres
angeschaut, hab mir auch zum Beispiel Domina Filme
angeschaut und vor allem vor dem Screen
fand ich fand ich es geil. Und ich bin
natürlich irgendwann mit meiner
Problematik, als es völlig aus dem Ruder
gelaufen ist, auch mal auf die Frage
gekommen, wie wäre es denn, ich hatte
das vorhin schon mal erwähnt, wenn ich mal
ein paar Sachen ausprobiere, also bin
ich mal zu einer Domina gegangen,
zwei, drei Mal und habe dann verschiedene Dinge
ausprobiert und festgestellt, dass viele
Dinge mir da gar nicht gefallen,
die ich mir auf dem Bildschirm als geil
suggeriert habe. Also von daher finde
ich das noch ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen,
gut, ich guck mir das an und dann.
Aber mit dem Wissen bist du zur Domina
gegangen, hast es ausprobiert und hast
festgestellt: Okay, ist doch nichts für mich
und dann hast du es gelassen. Was ist
-schlecht daran?
-Aber die Illusion. Also das Verhältnis, in
dem ich mir diese Filme vor dem Screen
angeschaut habe und aus diesem Akt
der Verzweiflung dann es einfach
mal ausprobiert habe. Das steht nicht
im Verhältnis. Also die Filme
sind auf einer Skala von hier bis Tokio
und die drei Mal, die ich bei einer Domina
war, waren dann der Akt der Verzweiflung.
Und dann habe ich zum Glück
rausgefunden okay, das Genre, da habe ich mir so viele
Filme angeguckt und mich da so dran
gelabt. Im echten Leben hat es mich nicht
-abgeholt.
-Warum bist du nach vorne gegangen?
Ich bin nach vorne gegangen, weil ich da zustimme.
Es kann auf jeden Fall sein,
dass man diese Erfahrung macht, dass du
merkst Okay, das gefällt mir im Porno,
das gefällt mir nicht, da bin ich genauso.
Also ich habe auch schon gemerkt, ich mach
total gerne Stepdad-Pornos und trotzdem
würde ich niemals mit meinem Stiefvater
schlafen. Also das ist, finde ich vollkommen
in Ordnung und nachvollziehbar.
-Ja.
-Ich finde das auch ganz, ganz wichtig. Was
wirklich sehr oft vergessen
wird, ist halt das, was wir da machen,
wenn wir vor oder hinter der Kamera
stehen ist, dass wir demjenigen der sich
das anschaut, das kann auch mal
auf Deutsch gesagt in die Hose gehen,
aaber eine Illusionseelt
verschaffen möchten und wir möchten ihn abholen,
da wo er selbst für sich niemals
hingehen kann, weil er eventuell verheiratet ist
zwei Kinder hat. Hund, Katze, Maus.
Das was man halt einfach an Alltagsproblemen
hat. Und es gibt ihm einen Moment
der Zuflucht und das, was vor der Kamera
läuft. Ich glaube, da stimmst du mir
zu. Das ist das, was wir machen. Das ist,
wir spielen jemandem ein Szenario
vor und möchten ihn einladen, daran
mit teilzuhaben. Ich weiß, das hört
sich total bescheuert an und viele sehen ihn
als Porno. Hallo, aber so
ist es letztendlich. Wir teilen
unsere Leidenschaft und für mich ist
immer der Grundkonsens, dass ich sage Mensch,
ist doch schön, wenn sich das im besten
Falle auch noch Mann und Frau zusammen
angucken, die beide wieder
zueinander finden. Happy Family und das ist
letztendlich der Grundkonsens,
was ich- Natürlich gibt es solche Sachen
und das ist dramatisch. Und dass wir immer
höher, schneller, weiter und verschiedene
Sexpraktiken, aber da müssen wir auch diskutieren,
was ist normal? Wer bestimmt
im Sexuellen Normalität? Das ist
ganz schwierig. Das kannst du fast nicht
machen. Das Einzige, was ich halt
sage. Okay, Kinder sollten kein Hardcore-Porno
zu Gesicht bekommen. Ich bin zum Beispiel,
mach ich mich wahrschienlich
auch unbeliebt mit, ich bin zum Beispiel
auch dafür, dass durchaus auch 16-jährige
bestimmte Pornos sehen dürfen. Weil sind
wir doch mal ganz ehrlich: Aufklärung
in der Schule, wo fangen wir denn da an?
Bei Bienchen und Blümchen? Die Eltern
oberpeinlich mit denen darüber
zu sprechen. Und da bin ich dabei,
dass natürlich nicht es vermittelt
werden soll, dass Analsex, Gangbang oder sonst
etwas, etwas normales sind für das erste
Mal Geschlechtsverkehr. Weil ich finde,
man sollte erst mal Erfahrungen
sammeln und sich langsam irgendwo rein grooven.
Aber ich finde auch, dass gewisse
Pornografie mit 16 vollkommen in Ordnung
-ist.
-Jetzt würde ich gerne mal eure Meinung
dazu wissen. Schreibt mir gerne mal in die Kommentare.
Was sind denn eure Erfahrungen
mit Pornos gucken? War das für euch
irgendwie aufklärerisch? Habt ihr euch
da neu orientieren können? War es eine Orientierungshilfe
oder habt ihr eher
Verstörendes gesehen? Hat euch das irgendwie
geschadet? Schreibt auch gerne
mal in die Kommentare, wie ihr mit Pornos
umgegangen seid. Vielleicht früher,
vielleicht heute. Was hat sich
geändert? Da bin ich sehr gespannt. Und jetzt haben
wir ganz viel mal gesammelt, was es auch positive
Effekte haben kann, wenn man
Pornokonsum eben nicht
stigmatisiert, sondern ganz offen damit umgehen kann.
Aber wenn wir und das ist ja auch ein bisschen
das Thema dieser Sendung,
wenn wir über Regulierungsfragen
reden, müssen wir auch mal sagen, da reden
wir vor allem über Schutz von Minderjährigen.
Und in Deutschland sind
halt Pornos für u18 verboten. Es gibt
ein Gesetz dafür und es gibt es verschiedene
Landesmedienanstalten, die für die Durchsetzung
dieses Gesetzes zuständig,
die nun sagen, okay, wer als pornografischer
Anbieter eben es nicht
hinbekommt, U18 auszuschließen,
dann müssen wir jetzt mit der mit der Keule
kommen in Teilen. Also reden wir über
Netzsperren, wenn man eben nicht
nachweisen kann, dass nur über
18-jährige das konsumieren. Du wolltest was dazu
-sagen.
-Was die Medienanstalten sagen bzw die die
die Jugend-Kommission, die sagen nicht
nur Minderjährigen sollen sich keine Pornos,
die sagen jeder Erwachsene der sich
ein Porno anschauen möchte, möchte bitte
mit dem Ausweis zur Post und sagen
Gut, schönen Tag, ich bin der Herr Max Müller
und ich möchte jetzt gerne mal ein Hentai
Porno angucken. Und dann sagt der Mensch
an der Post: Ja, Herr
Müller, viel Spaß beim Wichsen
mit dem Hentai-Tentakel-Porno.
Das ist eine Eingrenzung der sexuellen
-Selbstbestimmung. Das ist absurd.
-Aber auf der anderen Seite Wir haben
dieses Gesetz. Und da sagen
viele, wenn wir ein Gesetz haben, müssen
-wir es auch durchsetzen.
-Aber das Gesetz ist Paragraf 184. Sagt
nicht, dass ich mich mit meinem
Ausweis identifizieren muss. Das sagt
die Kommission. Das Gesetz sagt, nur U18-jährige
sollten kein Zugang zu Pornos
haben. Darüber können wir gerne
reden. Was ist die bestmögliche technologische
Lösung, um eben zu verhindern? Ich bin
total bei uns alle einig, dass 18-jährige
-keine Hardcore Pornos gucken sollten.
-Was ist denn auch mit Datenschutz zum
Beispiel? Also wenn irgendwelche
Datenbanken generiert werden mit Name,
Personalausweis. Ich stehe auf Anal
Pornos und auf die und die Pornos
-und auf Natursekt. Na dann-
-Es ist irre.
-es ein Leak geben in dieser Datenbank
und dann gibt es Riesenprobleme. Ich frage
mich, wie das umgesetzt werden soll.
Deswegen auch wieder Ich finde das total
gut, diesen Diskurs, den wir führen,
weil es geht am Ende um Aufklärung und alleine
dieser Diskurs trägt zur Aufklärung.
Ich glaube, das ist so das Kernelement.
Ich habe gemerkt, ihr seid alle, wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe, bitte Hand
heben, wenn es jemand anders
sieht. Ihr seid dagegen, dass Menschen,
alle Menschen, die Pornos gucken
wollen, im Internet sich mit Ausweis beim Postamt
-ausweisen müssen. Heike sieht das auch so?
-Sehe ich sehr kritisch, auch von den
Leuten. Wir hinterlassen sehr viele
Spuren im Internet und gerade
wenn wir im sozialen Medien uns
bewegen, sind wir natürlich sehr transparent.
Das ist uns oftmals gar nicht so
bewusst und da sehe ich auch Schwierigkeiten.
Jetzt müssen wir natürlich nur fragen
Also es gibt ja diese Vorschläge. Es gibt ja
diese Vorschläge von von namhaften
Politikern und Politikerinnen,
die das durchsetzen wollen, die dann
auch mit Netzsperren und so weiter drohen.
Die wiederum haben auch, die sind
heute nicht hier. Aber es gibt ja durchaus
Menschen, Eltern in Deutschland, die sagen
Ja, verdammt noch mal, natürlich muss
das so gemacht werden, weil ich will
meine Kinder schützen. Was antwortet
-ihr diesen Eltern?
-Ja wirklich, erst mal an die eigene Nase.
Also noch mal ich bin dabei. Ja, und ich sehe
das auch so kritisch, wie wir gerade
gesagt haben mit Ausweis und so,
weil wo ist die, wo ist die Privatsphäre?
Wenn das wirklich mal, wie wir gerade
schon besprochen haben, geleakt wird
oder sonst irgendwas, da hängen
Existenzen dran, das geht einfach nicht. Das ist
-schwierig zu regulieren.
-Ein 16-jähriger kann diese Netzsperre,
-innerhalb 30 Sekunden mit VPN umgehen.
-Absolut. Aber jetzt versetzt euch bitte
mal kurz, nur damit wir das mal klar
ziehen in die Lage einer Mutter, die sagt
Moment mal! Also wir haben zum Beispiel
Alkoholverbot für unter 16-jährige.
Das heißt, wenn mein Kind in Supermarkt
geht und mit einer Flasche Wodka
rauskommt, dann kann ich zum Supermarkt
gehen und sagen Dich zeige ich an, weil du
gegen das Gesetz gehandelt hat.
Und dieselbe Mutter sagt Pass mal auf,
Pornografie für Minderjährige ist
verboten, aber mein Kind kann da einfach
hingehen und sich die Pornografie
holen. Also müssen wir das verbieten.
-Was antwortet ihr?
-Der Mutter muss man sagen Leider lebt sie
ein bisschen in einer illusorischen
Welt, wenn sie denkt, dass ihr 16-jähriger
jugendlicher Jugendlicher noch nie
mit Alkohol in Berührung gekommen wäre.
Aber 15? Na okay, mit 16 darf man
gewisse Sachen, dass sie noch nie mit Alkohol
in Berührung gekommen wären. Die sind
mit Alkohol zwar, natürlich ist es verboten,
aber die sind damit in Berührung
gekommen. Das gleiche gilt auch für Pornografie
und deswegen müssen wir sowohl Eltern
als auch die Jugendlichen selber,
vielleicht auch schon die Kinder
aufklären, damit eben genauso Sachen-
14-jährige, die haben keine Ahnung was ein Gangbang
ist und dann sagt aber vielleicht
jemand Hey, wir machen einen
Nachmittag bei mir ein Gangbang. Hast du Bock drauf?
Ich bin vielleicht verknallt in die Person.
Da sage ich Ja, klar, ich mache
alles, was du sagst. Wenn ich aber
meinem 14 15-jährigen erklärt habe, ich muss
es nicht zeigen, um Gottes Willen,
aber erklärt habe, was ist ein Gangbang?
Kann es sich dann eben genau dagegen
entscheiden und sagen Was gehen mit dir
ab? Auf gar keinen Fall. Wir müssen
so viel mehr Aufklärungsarbeit leisten.
Ich sage jetzt Wir, der Staat, wir als Gesellschaft
müssen Aufklärung leisten.
Jetzt werden wahrscheinlich einige
Eltern sagen Ja, toll! Also bleibt es jetzt
an uns hängen. Also ich muss mich
jetzt informieren, was soll ich denn jetzt
-machen?
-Also ich finde es sollte einfach an
verschiedenen Stellen einfach Maßnahmen
erfolgen. Also ganz wichtig finde ich ist,
dass man einfach eine offene
Diskussion führt und damit nicht mit erhobenem
Zeigefinger und sagen, dass ist alles
schlecht. Bei Pornografie ist eshalt so,
also man darf es nicht ins Schlechte,
aber auch nicht nur sagen, das ist super.
Es kann auch sexuelle Fantasien rauben
in dem Sinne, dass es sie ersetzt, dass man
einfach gar keine Fantasien
mehr entwickelt, sondern dass man
diesen Pornofilm hat. Also
man muss. Einfach schauen, dass man
sowohl auf Elternseite, Ich habe
eine 12-jährige Tochter und ich habe
ihr auch ganz offen gesagt Ich bekomme
jetzt Screenshots alle 20 Minuten
und ich kann- Einmal in der Woche
gehe ich da mal kurz rüber. Das weiß sie.
Und ich möchte nicht, dass du mit deinen
zwölf Jahren Pornografie schaust.
Ich möchte auch nicht, dass du
gewaltverherrlichende Sachen schaust.
Und ich möchte auch nicht, dass du
Candy Crush die ganze Zeit spielst, sondern du
kannst ein paar Sachen mit deinen
Freunden chatten und du kannst Phase sechs Vokabeln
lernen oder so etwas, so was und so,
oder nach Geschenkideen Do it yourself suchen.
Aber ich spreche das konkret an, das finde
ich ganz, ganz wichtig. Und jetzt mal die-
Aber die Sache mit der Kontrolle, mit den Screenshots,
mit dieser Überwachungsvideos
-kann-
-Das ist die Funktion, auch wenn meine
Tochter sich eine App runterladen
möchte, muss ich die freigeben und dann entscheide
ich schon, ob meine Tochter Instagram
kriegt oder nicht. In diesem Fall nicht.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite
wissen wir das Verhältnis präventive Maßnahmen
und das ist so etwas, das man
auch von staatlicher Seite bestimmte
Zugangsbeschränkungen macht,
durchaus einen Effekt hat. Das sehen
wir zum Beispiel beim Rauchen.
Beim Alkohol ist der Staat dann weniger
konsequent, aber beim Rauchen haben
wir über viele Verhältnispräventive Maßnahmen
mittlerweile einen deutlich
geringeren Anteil von Nikotinsüchtigen in unserer
Gesellschaft durch Limitierung des
Zugriffs. Das macht es unbequem, das macht
Sand ins Getriebe. Und das kann
natürlich durchaus auch dazu führen,
dass der eine oder andere auch abgehalten
wird. Deswegen ist, sagen wir mal
die Umsetzung extrem schwierig im Internet.
Auf der anderen Seite muss man
sich schon Gedanken machen, ob auch von staatlicher
Seite, ob das nicht
nur bei den Eltern oder bei der Schule
bleibt, sondern dass man vielleicht auch,
ja sagen wir mal, staatliche
Interventionen macht, die dann eben
diesen Zugang beschränken im Sinne
von Verhältnis präventiven Maßnahmen.
Und dann ganz kurz, damit ihr auch antworten
könnt Was meinst du damit? Also,
-was heißt das konkret?
-Na ja, das schon in irgendeiner Weise.
Zumindest so solche Hinweise, außer
dieses Ich bin 18, Yes/No, also dass man-
Ich kann nicht die technische Umsetzung
machen und ich weiß auch, dass man relativ
schnell Wege findet, um das Ganze
zu vermeiden. Ich finde, das hat
eine Signalwirkung auch in der Bevölkerung,
wo oftmals gesagt wird,
auch das ist ja alles in Ordnung oder so
was, es hat jemand ein Smartphone, hat
es ruhig im Zimmer, ja, da haben
wir gar keinen Raum, auch gar keinen,
also brauchen uns nicht mal bemühen
oder so was. Das ist einfach ein Bewusstsein
schafft. Ja, es ist ein Genussmittel.
Aber in Überdosis Genossen kann
das auch tatsächlich Schäden
verursachen. Und deswegen, wie man das genau umsetzt,
-ich bin nicht der Technologe, aber-
-Du willst hier stärkere Signale.
Es gibt es in anderen Bereichen, ja,
beim Nikotin, beim Alkohol, wo durchaus
regulativ gearbeitet wird. Und das hat
manchmal- Es unbequem zu machen
oder ein bisschen die Hürde zu erhöhen,
kann durchaus etwas erreichen.
So, und bevor jetzt Ihr seid sofort
wieder alle dran. Aber Yma habe ich schon lange
nicht gehört und würde gerne
mal hören: Was denkst du darüber?
Größere Signalwirkung?
Präventivmaßnahmen, staatliche Limitierung zumindest? Was ist
-deine Antwort?
-Ich finde den Grundgedanken der
Limitierung gar nicht so schlecht. Also
ich wäre auch dafür, dass man zum Beispiel
Pornos hat, die FSK zwölf sind, FSK
16 bis 18 sind. Das wäre ja schon irgendwo
eine Einordnung oder Limitierung. Aber
ich finde, diese Signalwirkung ist komplett
zu regulieren und beispielsweise
Ausweis hin zu legen oder anderweitig Daten
abzugeben, das sendet es eher das Signal,
dass es etwas Gefährliches ist
oder dass alle Pornos eben schlecht
sind. Ich finde es nur schwierig, die also alle
Pornos oder die Pornoindustrie
an sich so zu verteufeln.
Ich bin da bei dir, ehrlich gesagt,
wenn wir die gesamte Industrie verteufeln,
so wie du es gesagt hast, was wir schaffen,
ist das viel weniger Leute,
die auch einen ästhetischen
Anspruch, einen ethischen Anspruch haben
in der Pornografie, dass die das auch machen
können. Je mehr
wir diese Hindernisse, die du
nennst, du vergleichst Nikotin und Pornografie.
Ich glaube, es ist schwierig. Nikotin
ist wirklich ein Suchtmittel. Ja, das ist.
Sorry, das ist nicht das Gleiche. Es ist
so, sie hat auch Pornografie gleichgesetzt
mit gewaltverherrlichend. Finde das alles
sehr heikel und ich glaube, je mehr
wir diese Hindernisse stellen, die du
gerade nennst und denkst, ich verstehe
deinen Gedanken und wo der herkommt.
Ich kann es wie gesagt nachvollziehen.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht die Lösung.
FSK 12/16 andere Arten und Weisen,
diese Pornografie zu kategorisieren,
in den Film Genre einfach reinzunehmen.
Das würde helfen, dass es mehr
Diversität gibt, dass mehr Leute einfach
unterschiedliche Pornos machen,
dass unterschiedliche Körper, Sexualitäten,
Sexualpraktiken und eben nicht
nur Pornos gemacht werden, die nicht
nur auf den sexuellen Reiz
anspielen, sondern einfach andere Ansprüche haben.
Und wir schaffen das nur, indem wir das wirtschaftlich
einfacher machen
für Menschen. Je mehr Hindernisse
wir stellen, desto, ich sage jetzt mal,
-eng wird das Angebot sein.
-Jetzt darf erst mal Alex antworten.
Ich bin jetzt auch nach vorne
gegangen, weil ich so auf einer Linie mit dir bin.
Diversität in Pornografie ist, also
wenn ich zurückblicke, was mir auch total
gefehlt hat, ich habe auch mittlerweile
feministische Pornos gesehen, also
aus einem anderen und aus einer anderen
Perspektive, Produktionen gesehen,
die tatsächlich auch einen Effekt
haben, suggeriere ich mir jetzt mal selbst,
was sie mit meinem Gehirn machen.
Das ist total toll und ich glaube, das ist
ein guter Weg und auch darüber
Aufklärung zu machen. Gar nicht so in your face
Aufklärung, sondern durch
Produktionen, die eben dann auf eine andere Art
und Weise aufklären. Ich glaube,
was mir hier gerade fehlt bei der ganzen
Diskussion wir vergleichen die reale
Welt mit der digitalen Welt.
Und die Signalwirkung finde ich auch super
gut, wenn es irgendwelche Blocker gibt
oder so, aber machen wir uns nichts
vor. Ich glaube, dass wenn die Blocker
bei den großen Pornoseiten am Start
sind, kommt der nächste Server, der einfach
auf einer anderen Insel gebaut wird.
Und dann sind die Pornos wieder zugänglich,
auch ohne diese Blocker. Und das hat
man in der realen Welt nicht.
Wenn ich als Minderjähriger Alkohol
kaufen will, dann muss ich entweder einen
18-jährige finden, der mir das kauft
oder mich durchschleusen mit einem gefälschten
Pass. Das sind krassere Hürden,
als einfach im Netz mir eine andere URL
rauszusuchen, die einfach
noch nicht geblockt ist.
Wir haben jetzt, ich glaube, 27 Mal
das Wort Aufklärung gehört. Heute vollkommen
richtig sind wir uns auch alle einig.
Aber vielleicht könnt ihr noch mal konkreter
werden und sagen Was heißt das denn?
Sexualkunde, bessere Lehrpläne?
Politische Anstrengung? Brauchen wir ein Sexualkunde-Minister?
Ein Ministerium
was sich damit auseinandersetzt? Also
ich suche wirklich. Also wir sehen haben
das Problem erkannt. Wir wollen
vulnerable Menschen schützen, wenn sie schützenswert
-sind. Wie? Bitte, Paulita!
-Ich bin nicht die Expertin, aber ich fange
an und bestimmt könnte ihr weiter
ergänzen. Eine inklusive Lust orientierte
Sexualaufklärung in Schulen. Das heißt,
Sexualaufklärung ist oft Penis in Vagina
ist Sex, dann wird man schwanger.
Wie werde ich nicht schwanger und wie werde
ich nicht geschlechtskrank. Das ist
eine sehr enge Sicht auf Sexualität,
auch wichtig, aber wirklich sehr eng.
Es muss Sexualität als Lust dargestellt
werden, es muss inklusiv sein. Das heißt
wie gesagt, unterschiedliche Identitäten,
Sexualitäten, Sexualpraktiken
müssen behandelt werden und es muss darüber
-gesprochen werden: Was ist Pornografie?
-Absolut. Das die Schule muss das anders
aufbauen. Wenn wir zum Beispiel
den Berliner Lehrplan anschauen: Bereits
in der ersten Klasse Grundschule ist
eigentlich Sexualkunde mit auf dem Plan
und ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch
war. Ich kann von meiner Schulzeit reden,
ich hatte Aufklärungsunterricht
relativ früh, dann noch mal neunte Klasse,
dann noch mal Oberstufe und so und da muss
man schauen, dass man daraus vielleicht
Projektwochen macht, wenn man
Sexualität und Lust und all das mit rein nimmt.
Biologie liegt da relativ nah. Wir können
in Ethik Bedingungen von Pornos
besprechen, zum Beispiel wir können
in Geschichte die Geschichte von Was sind
Gesetze gewesen, wie war das politisch?
Und so weiter besprechen. Wir können
in Deutsch, Englisch,
Französisch, Literatur dazu lesen. Also das ist
fächerübergreifend machbar. Aber dafür
bräuchten wir Erwachsene, die sich trauen,
über dieses Thema zu sprechen,
das anzusprechen und nicht hinter
vorgehaltener Hand dann
Liebemachen nennen oder so.
Du hast wirklich den Nagel auf den Kopf
getroffen. Ich glaube, ein riesengroßes
Problem unserer Gesellschaft, Ist halt
diese unfassbar schreckliche Doppelmoral,
dass Menschen halt einfach hingehen
und sagen: Oh Porno, pfui, pfui, pfui!
Da sprechen wir mal nicht drüber.
Ja, aber sich dann auf der anderen Seite
beschweren, wenn dann irgendwelche
schlimmen Dinge passieren und das finde
ich persönlich total schlimm, weil Sex
ist ja nichts schlimmes und diese ganze
Sexworkerschaft ist ja nichts
schlimmes. Wir haben einen Industriezweig gepickt,
womit wir Leuten in erster Linie
Freude bereiten, dass es manchmal ausgenutzt
wird, Klar, logisch. Aber
die Aufklärung muss da sein.
Erfreulicherweise stehen viele von euch
relativ weit vorne. Eigentlich steht
ihr alle weit vorne, noch nicht
alle im Kompromiss drin. Alex ist so schon
sehr nah an der Mitte. Mal sehen, ob wir euch
jetzt durch Kompromissvorschläge noch
ein bisschen weiter
auseinandertreiben können oder noch näher zusammenbringen
können. Erst mal die Frage an euch,
nachdem ihr das Ganze jetzt gehört habt:
Was glaubt ihr wäre die richtige
Maßnahme? Welche Kompromisslinie habt ihr gerade
im Kopf? Schreibt's uns in die Kommentare.
Wer weiß, vielleicht trifft sich ja
die eine oder andere Meinung hier
dann genau in der Mitte. Also wir sind
der Kompromissrunde. Ich würde euch
einen Vorschlag machen. Ich habe jetzt
aus der Diskussion ein bisschen
mitgenommen, ob es jetzt
Kompromissvorschlag oder sagen wir ein Vorschlag
für eine Maßnahme wäre.
Eine FSP, also eine freiwillige
Selbstkontrolle Porno, wie es bei der FSK
gibt oder FSF oder für die Gaming
Industrie gibt es das, also Labels,
die eine Orientierung geben können.
Das ist eher Blümchensex und das hier ist
super Hardcore. Und dann kann man
vorher als User/Userin, Eltern Staat,
vielleicht sogar auch schon als Produzent/Produzentin
vorher sagen das ist
so eine Richtung. Wer das initiiert,
ist natürlich die große Frage
im internationalen Markt. Vollkommen
klar. Aber man könnte ja zumindest darauf
hinwirken, dass man sagt: Hier in Deutschland
fangen wir an, wir verteilen
Labels. Vielleicht setzt sich
das mit einem guten Beispiel fort. Also
mein Vorschlag wäre, wir machen
eine freiwillige Selbstkontrolle Porno.
Wenn ihr sagt, guter Vorschlag,
gehe ich einen Schritt vor, wenn ihr sagt,
ist Quatsch, geht einen Schritt
zurück. Gut, ganz ehrlich. So nah waren sich
die Contestants lange nicht mehr.
Corona gibt es ja nicht mehr. So, jetzt könnt
ihr bitte in eure Gruppe mal die Köpfe
zusammenstecken und mal überlegen
und einen Vorschlag raushauen,
wie wir vielleicht uns dann alle gleich
-zum Ringelpiez treffen.
-Aber auch die ganzen Amateurs, die ihre
-Sachen hochladen. Relativ einfach.
-Auch die Frage an euch Was haltet ihr
davon, Labels zu verteilen im Internet
vielleicht grüne, orangene und rote,
dass man weiß, okay, das ist
wirklich super Hardcore, das ist irgendwie
die Gangbang-Rape-Fantasie und das da ist
der Blümchensex, dass man eine gewisse
Orientierung hat, vielleicht auch für Filter-Programme,
dann für Eltern. Ist
das besser als eine Netzsperre
oder schlechter? Schreibt uns gerne
-in die Kommentare.
-Technologisch halt standardisiert.
Welche Gruppe möchte anfangen? Ihr wart
zuerst fertig, also dürft ihr anfangen.
Also Drei-Schritt Programm.
Erstens: Anstatt Sperre wollen wir Filter
standardisieren. Das heißt, die Plattformen
können freiwillig auf ihren
Plattformen Filter anlegen. Das kann
man, das muss standardisiert werden, damit alle
Devices das haben. Und diese Filtern
sind viel schwieriger zu umgehen
als diese Sperre, die, wie gesagt,
jeder 12-jährige umgehen kann. Nummer zwei
Förderung von Pornografie. Das heißt,
aktuell ist es so in Deutschland,
dass alle Förderrichtlinien, also
von einigen Förderanstalten, explizit
eine Klausel haben, die sagt,
es werden keine pornografischen
oder gewaltverherrlichenden
Inhalte gefördert, also sind Gewalt
und Pornografoe eh
gleichgestellt. Komisch. Aber nichtsdestotrotz,
wenn wir diese Richtlinien ändern,
dann könnten andere Menschen ein Projekt
mit ästhetischen und anderen
Ansprüchen oder Geschichten, wie du vorhin gemeint
hast und viele andere Sachen könnte
sich bewerben. Ob sie die Förderung kriegen
oder nicht, ist eine andere
Frage. Aber dass man erst mal überhaupt
dieses Verständnis, dass Pornografie
was ist, was staatlich nicht erlaubt ist,
-das müssen wir erst mal ändern.
-Also eine Filmförderung für pornografische
-Inhalte.
-Es braucht keine spezifische Förderung,
-das ist super-
-Für Produzenten sowieso.
-wenn du es durchboxt, bin ich wirklich
dabei. Aber es reicht schon mal,
dass wir Porno als Film sehen, dass wir sagen
Nein, ich kann einen Horrorfilm
bei der Filmförderung einreichen.
Könnte man auch sagen Gefällt uns nicht, aber
ich darf nicht ein Porno
bei der Filmförderung einreichen.
-Okay, das sind zwei.
-Unser drittes, aber auf jeden Fall
eigentlich das Wichtigste
von uns allen: Aufklärung.
Okay, das war jetzt ein Bandel, drei
Maßnahmenpaket. Würdet ihr sagen, das ist
-schlau oder sagt ihr zu kurz gedacht?
-Nein, ich bin dabei.
-Das kann man so weiterdenken.
-Keine Einwände. Dürfte jetzt noch ein
kleines Stück nach vorne gehen. So
umgekehrt. Was habt ihr noch für einen
-Vorschlag?
-Pragmatischer Ansatz als jetzt bei mir
ehemaliger Heavy Porn User. Es gibt
ja immer diese Vorspann Videos auf den Tube
Seiten. Na, bist du immer noch
am wichsen? Komm doch jetzt und triff
-deine Geschlechtspartner in in real life.
-Also die Werbung meinst du.
Ja genau diesen Vorspann, bevor der eigentliche
Film losgeht. Und den ab
und zu, in welchem Algorithmus müsste
man dann ausverhandeln, ersetzen durch einen
Vorspann, der eigentlich
ähnlich funktioniert, vom Wording aber
in die andere Richtung auch mal
kommuniziert. Und zwar sagt: Na,
immer noch am wichsen. Meinst du das-
Also ich habe jetzt das Wort nicht parat.
Aber meinst du nicht, dass das vielleicht
ungesund ist, oder? Schau doch mal
auf dieser Seite vorbei. Genau.
Also das müsste man dann aber, dass man
diesen Vorspann, den jeder sieht, den niemand
überspringen kann, ersetzt durch
einen aufklärenden Hinweis, und dass man
Porno Plattformen dazu verpflichtet,
den ab und zu zu setzen und dass man
dann sozusagen in seinem Tunnel das ab
und zu mal mitbekommt. Und wenn man
vielleicht das 4./5. Mal mitbekommt,
dass man dann vielleicht draufklickt
und sich ein paar Infos abholt, damit so
Leuten wie mir vielleicht
ein bisschen besser geholfen ist.
-Also Aufklärung durch die Hintertür quasi.
-Genau.
Es hat bei dem Thema
eine andere Bedeutung.
-Es ist bei dem Thema echt schwierig-
-Ja, aber beim Autofahren, da wird ja zum
Beispiel auch manchmal
eingespielt: Du bist schon drei Stunden am Fahren.
Jetzt mal eine Pause. Also so, dass man
oder eben vielleicht auch bei Problemen
schau dir das und das an, also sagen
wir mal wirklich auch die problematische Seite
mal anspricht oder mal einen
Hinweis setzt, dass man diesen Autopiloten,
wenn man da einmal so
eingefahren ist, unterbricht.
-In der Not-Situation.
-Also Hinweise. Ich nenne es mit Absicht
nicht Warnhinweis, weil es soll ja
nicht abschrecken sein, sondern nur kurze
Erinnerung. Achtung, alles okay noch
bei dir? So, das war ja ein sehr konkreter
Vorschlag, den man vielleicht
sogar relativ leicht sogar umsetzen könnte.
-Frage an euch Findet ihr die Idee gut?
-Kurze Rückfrage Kommt das direkt beim
ersten Film oder wie bei Streamingdiensten
und im Auto nach einer gewissen Minuten
-Anzahl, wenn was läuft?
-Das ist jetzt die Frage. Das haben wir
selber noch nicht beantwortet. Also
das ist der Algorithmus. Vielleicht kann man
den so einstellen, dass eben
nicht das erste Video direkt das bekommt,
sondern erst, nachdem man wirklich
fünf Filme gesehen hat oder so, dass dann
-der Hinweis kommt.
-Auch nicht nach einem Standard-Modus,
sondern nach einem Zufallsmodus.
Ich glaube, das wäre vielleicht günstig.
Für mich geht es um eine Verweildauer,
die ich auf einer Seite verbringe.
Und das macht Netflix
auch. Guckst du noch? Also genau.
Genau deswegen frag ich,
automatisch, also läuft gar nicht weiter.
Ich fands super. Also ich war
überrascht, aber ich habe es ein stückweit
auch erwartet, weil ich war ja nicht
so komplett gefixt auf der einen Seite.
Von daher schön, dass wir uns
alle näher gekommen sind.
Ich finde es auch total schön
und ich glaube, ich glaube nicht,
dass wir repräsentativ für die gesamte
Gesellschaft da stehen. Wir waren
irgendwie schon eine homogene Gruppe
und trotzdem will ich glauben, dass es zeigt,
dass wir gesellschaftlich schon
inmitten eines Kulturwandels sind und wir wollen
was ändern und es geht- Wie genau ist
unterschiedlich. Aber wir wollen mehr über
Sexualität reden und deswegen freue
ich mich, dass wir heute waren
-und dass wir zusammengekommen sind.
-Vielen Dank, dass ihr euch die Mühe
gegeben hat, Mühe gemacht habt,
hier zusammen zu kommen. Und wir sind
tatsächlich so nah zusammengekommen,
wie, glaube ich, bei noch keiner anderen Folge
vorher. Sechs Leute im Kompromissfeld.
Vielleicht ist es auch kein Zufall,
dass wir über Pornografie gesprochen
haben, dass wir alle ein bisschen näher
zusammengerückt sind. Herzlichen Dank dafür.
Das waren 13 Fragen. Danke. Danke.
Meine ganz persönliche Meinung ist:
Wenn wir über Netzsperren diskutieren,
dann würden wir ja die juristische
Brechstange auspacken, die im Zweifel
dem Jugendschutz wenig hilft
und sogar in Sachen Datenschutz
und Überwachungstendenzen mehr
schaden könnte als helfen. Wir freuen uns,
wenn ihr 13 Fragen gewogen bleibt.
Hier könnt ihr unseren Kanal abonnieren.
Hier gibt es ein weiteres Video von 13
Fragen und hier gibt es ein weiteres Video
zum Thema.